two all rise for the honorable judge
ethan klein this episode is sponsored
by mint mobile
[Music]
good afternoon everybody please be
seated
welcome to content court order
this court is now in session
good evening everybody or morning
whatever time it is
today it is my understanding that we
take a look
at a channel known as the prince family
this is a channel a family vlog that is
run by
damian prince and bianca reigns
a married couple incidentally with two
different last names
does not bode well for them does it they
are married right abey
yes this is not looking good already
they have three kids dj kyrie
and nova in their video they highlight
their days
challenges games and other contents this
channel is being charged with committing
the following
crimes terrible intros
disturbing click bait over
sexualized content fake
pranks which reminds you holds a is a
capital offense in this
jurisdiction and exploiting
children we will
be hearing the pleadings by the
plaintiff
a b who will be the prosecuting attorney
against the ace family
not ice uh well they're next but
actually i meant
i meant the uh prince family there's too
many families to keep track of
on youtube and they're all brazy
and we als and then so and then the
defending council
is aien we will hear
all the pleadings of both sides and at
the end we will come
to a verdict on each count
council do you have your opening
statement
let us begin with a b his opening
statement thank you your honor yes i
would like to begin by saying i am here
on behalf of the youtube community
as a whole we must come together and not
let these cringe channels fly under the
radar
any longer it is our moral obligation
to shed light on it and put a stop to it
that's all your honor thank you ab for
the opening statement
aien do you have anything to say on
behalf
of your client the not
ace fit the prince family
uh first off i'd like to make this quick
i'm running low on battery i will have
to charge
soon but i think this channel is lit
it's exciting their ability to inflict
pain on their viewers and each other
is admirable okay
and that hardly seems like a defense but
uh you are
the professional
i just have to say this content does not
grind my gears
so you are a fan of their content which
does not bode well for them thank you
council
well let us begin straight into
our first uh crime here
we are be we are charging the prince
family
with terrible intros
please proceed prosecuting counsel a b
with our first um uh
evidence thank you your honor so one of
the first commonalities
we see amongst these family channels is
that
they all have these horrible
cringe-filled intros
and thanks to the wife bianca the prince
family
may have the top spot if you please take
a look at the first exhibit
you will see what i'm talking about uh
we'll opening
the compilation of bianca now
and entering for the record exhibit ah
this is really how she starts her videos
oh my god every time how does
nobody click off immediately
what no wow
why do your eyes look so big in this
[Applause]
some claim that she does this to reach
the 10-minute mark
so we're halfway through this video uh i
think the court has seen enough of
evidence of exhibit a
so the charge is that
it's an awful intro and while i won't
cast my verdict just yet
i have to say that the court finds it
very offensive
indeed yeah i mean this is a popular
channel
and and it's crazy that people don't
click off immediately i mean they have a
lot of views they've got like seven
million
subs and uh this is very persuasive
evidence every video starts like that
a b every video every single one
aie and do you have a defense of this
intro
i really don't see a problem with it i
mean say you're a first time viewer
she's just letting you know her name
what's the big deal interesting defense
do you not find it grating that it could
possibly
deter anybody who has a sane state of
mind from watching the content
i mean it's like say you get distracted
oh wait
i didn't catch her name what was it oh
she's still saying it
good yeah fascinating defense i find
that very persuasive
moving on to exhibit b we have they're
being charged with acting
ratchet prank to see how my husband
reacts
bad idea another awful intro let's
examine acting ratchet
look at how you acting you acting very
unusual
unusual
you acting like a thought right now bro
what in god's name is this this has two
million views and people love it look at
the likes
these peop this has seven million i mean
hang on let me watch this [ __ ] again
that's it
yeah that's awful and i don't really
know what to say
it's obviously fake too that's the other
thing
like i like the idea that there's like a
family running a prank channel
and every day they're making a video
acting crazy and it's like
what are you doing right
i have no idea you could be pranking me
right now by acting
ratchet give me my popsicle get
over here now no get over here
why are you acting like that what in
god's name
distract this one was called distracting
my husband while he's on my phone
revenge prank
now just to be clear i'm only looking at
the intros right maybe
correct husband wakes up in swimming
pool prank
oh why are you recording me cuz good
morning
damian damien you all right
why are you crying does he not know how
to swim
what's the premise there he doesn't know
how to swim he doesn't know how to swim
yes why is he in a pool
oh she pranked him he pranked him
correct we'll we'll explore that exhibit
more later on that obviously begs the
question can you get someone in a pool
without them knowing
real vs gummy food challenge
[Music]
this is disgusting this is how they
start their video
i swear to g i swear to god dude if i
try to
get myself eating a worm in the first
five seconds of a video youtube would
would nuke my whole they'd nuke my house
they just bomb my house but this has
three million views
it's from may of this year
this is recent y'all i don't get it well
you put family in the title of your
channel you can do anything
right is that the issue here
um interesting
the next exhibit is calling my wife the
b
word prank uh oh [ __ ]
call me bro
[Music]
again once again what is this what's the
prank a family uh
of a domestic violence prank
once again this video let's see what was
this update
this was from five months ago they're
hitting each other cursing each other
and the first 36
seconds and it has four million views i
mean what the hell
susan would call me on the phone be like
ethan you lost your mind
what's the difference between call of
duty and acting like
don't you find a crazy double standard
also how is this family content
that i'm not sure hey kids gather around
and watch
mom and dad physically attack each other
and call each other
the b word uh oh it's blurred though so
it's okay
what the [ __ ] uh coming up next coming
home from the gym fully dressed frank
what kind of prank is that
don't you usually come home from the gym
fully dressed
yes it did this is not my condom yes
this is not mine that bed is pretty epic
what just happened maybe
oh there was a prank that she found i'm
trying to stop it
i'm trying i don't know why the button
just doesn't click sometimes
she's excusing him of finding a condom
and it's it's not his and he has no idea
who's it is
so it's a prank though yeah and it's
crazy how they're like
pranking about like cheating and stuff
and then running running slow-mo of
their kids
[Music]
it's crazy man this shit's wild as [ __ ]
well they're making a good living at
least it's a cute baby actually nova
okay
there's a quite a lot of examples here
spin the mystery wheel challenge truth
or dare one spin
equals one dare let's see what you got
i know what's gonna happen bro
you what again you're having a
tongue in kissing on a family channel in
the first
30 seconds and i just don't get it how
is it
what what's happening here this is so
illegal
illegal yeah this is
this is a clear violation of the law
someone saved me hmm
catfishing my husband to see if he
cheats leads to real breakup somehow i
doubt that
i actually wanted you in the beginning
but i was already with bianca plus we
had kids
how did you already want her when you
met her through me
then i'm about to go grab somebody first
of all why are you grabbing viagra's
when you don't even use viagra's on me
you don't even take them
when you're with me so why are you
taking them with her you're trying to
last longer
so do you want me to expose you because
you don't laugh at them all
is that why you're trying to grab viagra
you last
five minutes damian stop like
i swear i will expose out of him don't
play with me so let me just get this
straight
first 30 seconds again i have to
emphasize youtube
has a rule that you can't have any
cursing or graphic content
especially and what is this dan
you clicked the stats for nerds button
for some reason what the [ __ ] did i
click i didn't click [ __ ]
your clicking game is it's something
it's this trackpad is insane i know why
don't you use a mouse
no how dare you this is my court
um so in the first 30 seconds it needs
to be totally clean but somehow
the prince family has found a way to
circumvent this world they have viagra
sex cursing on a family channel how is
this family content i truly don't
understand but this one has seven
million views
quite a popular video on their channel
and how big is their channel did we
seven million subscribers
and they have multiple channels they
have about five or six channels
why is this their this is their main
channel that's their main correct
and and who's the target audience of
this uh channel may i ask
i'm not sure i believe it's marketed to
be towards families but it doesn't
really make sense to me
right that certainly doesn't make sense
to the court either
well in inch and
obviously those those are all the
exhibits we have for the first section
of terrible
intros which i find uh before obviously
i'll pass my verdict at the end of the
session but ai in would you like to make
any statement on behalf of the
defendants
oh oh what were you guys talking to me
sorry i was just finishing up a real
verse gummy food challenge dramatic
taste test video
it was pretty entertaining they pulled
me in with that intro
so your argument is that the intro pulls
you
in and got you interested listen
your dishonor i would like to say whoa
hey hey excuse me i will hold you in
contempt of court aien
if you disrespect me like that again
it's your honor
please begin again
all right all right i'd like to draw
attention to your complete and utter
confusion
watching every exhibit would you
describe yourself as confused
i would i would um i would describe it
as a state of
i don't get you get i don't think you
can question the judge
you can't question the judge order
confusion was on your face
yes i was confused i was confused go
ahead proceed with your point
confusion leads to intrigue intrigue
leads to
further viewing to elaborate on the
feeling of confusion
which is what i would call a good intro
ladies and gentlemen
do you have anything that you want to
say to counter that
i don't think that's a good point
because you know when i when i was in
school for example
you know everyone was talking about this
this video when i was in elementary
school called two girls one cup and i
was interested to see what it was
and i follow through so it doesn't
always mean it's a good thing
intrigue is not always good ain is the
counterpoint that i'm understanding here
today
well i feel like i should make a verdict
now based on the pleadings
this court hears and appreciates
both sides clearly on youtube
it is a struggle to gain the attention
of of the audience
clearly they have they
they're pursuing just that as aien
correctly points out intrigue
leads to more views the question is are
there boundaries
are there boundaries you don't cross in
the pursuit of
views and introductions of course there
must be
and it's up to youtube to police those
boundaries is it not
is it not youtube's responsibility to
police the boundaries
for example they set the rules that you
can't curse and have sexual content in
the first first 30
seconds but these people of prince
family have found a way to
to still do that and find success so who
do we blame youtube or the prince family
yeah with tab yeah
the court on this count
while awful i will concede the court
sides with aie in wow
the intros are intriguing
and it's youtube's responsibility
to uphold the rules of the platform
i find the defendant on awful intros not
guilty
order order in the court your sound
bites are too quiet zack
order in the court i could barely hear
them that was me actually but no that
was dan order
there's a lot of murmuring who is
dancing who is that talking i'm sorry
about that
silence
are these not too loud is it too loud
when i bang the gavel
sounds really loud oh i mean okay
i think we're okay
the next point is disturbing click bait
clickbait is used among many youtubers
both respected
and non however the prince family ins
uh they use horrific and traumatic
events
to click bait and their audience even
though some
are fake and exaggerated
um clickbait interesting
okay never do that here so um does the
uh
defend the uh proxy cuter have any
opening statements
on the click bait
well uh yeah as you mentioned your honor
click bait is no new thing to youtube
and you know
creators on both sides use it but this
family definitely takes it
a level further the exhibits will
explain further
hmm can you explain abe
why is it that they why is it that their
click bait goes further than
regular click bait that you would is
commonplace on youtube
like on the street podcast highlights
channel
order in the court
[Music]
well they they're
it's kind of hard to describe you kind
of have to see it to believe it but they
insinuate that their children got hurt
or some kind of traumatic event happen
in their family
yeah wow and most of the time it's
severely exaggerated or it didn't happen
at all
so okay and yeah looking forward to that
and do you have any opening statement
for clickbait
i don't believe in clickbait as a
concept
it's all fair game baby
ian truly the johnny cochran of uh
youtube defense
a.b i think you underestimated aien i
did i severely did
yeah hey twitter world this is yours
truly
so allow me to point you guys towards
exhibit a
so this is from a title called her water
broke
the video starts with bianca telling her
husband damon that her water broke on
the floor
damon proceeds to rub his hands in it
before the title sequence that is
right that this is absolutely
horrifically disgusting
i mean they clearly just like threw
water on her
pubic area and dumped water on the floor
i mean this is just disgusting
also why so her water breaking why is
that sad you'll notice the emojis and
the bright heartbreak
why is that sad why are we saying it's
sad yeah are they trying to insinuate
that
did something terrible happen to
clickbait you in wow
maybe to the baby because water breaking
is not a bad thing
no it's exciting or i mean it's like it
is because by the time you want to give
birth you're like i'm done i'm ready i'm
over it i want to get rid of this baby
out of my stomach when the water breaks
it means you go to the hospital
yeah and and like i said like
we were just waiting for that because we
were just so over it
let me so i kind of want to see this
intro that was described
of him playing with the water bro
bro chill why does that look entirely
different wait yeah what
what's that why does it look oh there's
there's no water breaking oh that was a
joke
yeah there's no water breaking huh i
don't see nothing
don't see that it's magic you for real
touch it
this is all the forest well yeah because
she's her clothes aren't wet
man this this is but does the same from
the thumbnail actually happen
does this no no it doesn't and actually
the
water didn't break they don't know what
the liquid is oh my god
yeah that's that's so this is completely
manufactured just for the thumbnail
never happened what
36 minutes and it never happened this
truly is the art of clickbait
wow but that but the thing is you know
when you're making a vlog you kind of
have to clickbait something
but like to do something like that yeah
and to manufacture in such ways
is not is is really wild
okay let's move on to exhibit um
we got a vag zoom do you want me to
watch this a b a vag
zoom as you call it i think it gives a
better picture of uh
their type of content maybe is calling
attention to what he refers to as a vag
zoom see me what is what
where i don't see nothing you don't see
that
it's magic for real this is exactly what
i saw in the beginning
all right oh was it in the beginning bro
yeah they showed this in their intro was
that the vag zoom happened already
yeah yeah okay
i just found it interesting being that
it's a clear liquid and that it's not
real at all very interesting
next one oh my god the next one is
called no heartbeat
oh no they're literally click baiting
wait what it so what's the context of
this who doesn't have a heartbeat
and again with the sad emoji and the
heartbreak so beyona
bianca is pregnant yeah so she's
alluding that her
child has no heartbeat yeah and the
child was born healthy and fine
yes that is truly [ __ ]
obscene that is how would you so
crazy and what is the no heartbeat
actually referring to if anything at all
so at one point in the video they're not
able to find the heartbeat because the
baby's moving
yeah yeah that's normal when you're
doing a uh
ultrasound they just have to move it
around
but with the heart wow
as a father i find that extremely
disturbing and as a human being
as a person that was pregnant i would
never
joke about that it's just so
it's just like i wouldn't even want to
think about that
you they're like well we already have
two other what does it mean
they're like we just have the kids for
the videos anyway
so like the best click bait part is
being pregnant gives birth so if we
start over it's all good
i don't like it abey would you like to
draw our attention to any of these
bianca crying in pain while her husband
films let's see
some context here
wait i'm sorry it's all right sorry
sorry
wait it's all right what is this let me
let me see if he has to be crying
but it looks kind of manufactured to me
what is she crying about her
um she's not feeling well i believe
because of the uh
the pregnancy and she's worried she's
worried as well
but it turns out she's fine she's
currently having
a pain on her it turned out to be a
bladder infection
here's the thing this she only 29 weeks
y'all here's the thing
i'm gonna just straight out and call
call her a liar because she just click
baited her unborn baby dying
yeah so they're willing to lie about
literally anything that really causes a
question
anything they say or do in their vlogs
when you're willing to clickbait your
baby dying
but they have views and they have a lot
of subscribers so i just want 10 million
10 million views on this video do their
fans just not care
because i feel like if we did something
that it would be such a
scandal breach of everyone's trust you
know
yeah i think it's just a different side
of youtube
it's just a weird side of youtube that
frankly i'm not acquainted with and i
don't know what's going on
i mean i guess if you do it every day
then everyone just expects
yeah but stuff you can't clickbait your
child dying
you can't you literally can't i mean
because like even if you do
do that when you see this you're still
going to be like oh no
i have to find out if that actually
happened
weirdos here's a clip of what really
happened in the video
the baby was simply moving around and
they couldn't find its heartbeat
looks happy actually at first because
she moved so much
okay like the baby keeps moving and
every time that's it
it removes the wow that's shameful
oh my god so she actually did go to the
hospital for a bladder infection
so that's what they said why don't you
just say that why do you have to
clickbait your baby dying
i went to the hospital isn't that enough
isn't that enough but would you put it
past these people that call an ambulance
just for that
thumbnail i mean they lied about their
baby dying
yeah right you know
there's no limit that is compelling ai
ian i'm feeling very persuaded by what
i've just seen do you have anything to
say in their defense
ladies and gentlemen
uh i think we need to first define
what is clickbait clickbait is when you
see an image
or a title that causes you to click
and you are greeted with
information that is not matching what
you originally advertised
which results in anger confusion
feelings of being misled would you agree
with me
correct excuse me ela are you the judge
correct now
let's go through these videos the first
one i've crunched the numbers
they're crunched okay her water broke
1.6 million views the lac ratio
is 97 positive
no heartbeat 9.6 million views
96 positive ratio
all of these videos are received very
positively
so that was a good point you would have
to agree
that clickbait is when you mislead
someone
and cause them feelings of anger or
confusion
or being misled with these ratios
the viewers are satisfied therefore
the clickbait is not effective
wow ai ian is coming with some
strong are you gonna get off on a
technicality aren't they well that's
very
good that's a very good uh argument did
you yeah did you know ain't it was
coming here with straight up like
damn i think he downloaded the court
yeah which uh did you did you watch a
few good men or something
i've got judge judy downloaded straight
to my mainframe
all right well let's proceed this
actually we're uh we're at break time
oh at break time
no oh i'm sorry it's uh it's time it's
time to go to recess
the court shall now take a short recess
to thank our sponsor
and when we come back we will continue
in this case against the prince family
uh recess is uh take uh
take uh three minutes
this episode of content court is
sponsored by
mint mobile breaking up with your old
wireless provider just got a whole lot
easier thanks to mint
mobile they were the first company to
sell premium wireless service online
and now mint mobile is introducing their
unlimited data plan
for just thirty dollars a month that is
incredible mint mobile
let that sink in an unlimited data plan
for 30 bucks
how much is yours soon to be a x
wireless provider charging you more than
a lot more than 30 bucks
you know it's incredible how companies
like mobile have gotten the price down
across the board because back in the day
only
recently was like 150 bucks for
unlimited mint mobile is cutting all
those guys out and frankly i'd hate
dealing with all those
companies mint mobile is the way to go
30 bucks a month for
unlimited thank god for people like this
because who's going to afford to pay
these ridiculous phone bills i couldn't
when i was
broke you know and the thing you know
what they get you
you go unlimited it's too expensive for
me i don't want to pay 150
a month and you end up going over anyway
so you end up spending like even more
than that
mobile a month for people that hate
their phone bill and are ready to cut
ties with big wireless mint mobile
offers the premium
unlimited plan for just 30 dollars a
month
by going online only in limitating the
traditional cost of retail
mint mobile passes the savings on to you
all plans come with unlimited talk text
and high-speed data delivering on the
nation's largest
5g network use your
phone your own phone with any mint
mobile plan
and keep the same phone number along
with all existing
contacts see that's already better when
you go and you want to switch a phone or
whatever they're like
oh sorry you can't use that phone with
our network what
i own the phone mint mobile
if you're not 100 satisfied mint mobile
has you covered with their 10
day money back guarantee seven
seven day money back guarantee
break up with the big wireless and
switch to mobile premium unlimited
data plan for 30 bucks a month this is
how it comes by the way
boom sim card bada bing
there it is you pop it out you plug it
in
and you're good to go same contact same
phone 30 bucks a month
outrageous outrageous
to get your new unlimited wireless plan
for just 30 bucks a month
and get the plants shipped to your door
for free go to mintmobile.com
h3 that's mint mobile.com h3
cut your unlimited wireless bill to 30
bucks a month
at mintmobile.com h3
court is now in session on the matter of
horrific click bait a b do you have any
uh rebuttal to
ian yes well being that the defense
attorney doesn't have a heart
i could see how he doesn't find it a
problem that the family is clickbaiting
their child
dying so if you want to speak simply
analytics
and speak numbers if you go back to my
original contention i didn't
make the point that all people feel a
certain way
so being that majority don't have a
problem with it doesn't mean that it's
still not disturbing
that's all your honor so the court will
now make a verdict on the
issue of horrific click bait
now here's my thinking on this ela
although the click bait is effective in
their case
and as aien correctly points out that
the
the consumers of this doesn't seem to
have a problem with it
[Music]
um doesn't change the fact that
just because they're happy being lied to
doesn't change the fact that it is
horrific clickbait
the thing is the water breaking is
disgusting as one thing
but to lie about your child dying
is so beyond the pale as a parent and a
human being
it it horrifies me and
i feel like despite the fact that
they're you know
their audience doesn't mind i think that
the universe minds i have to agree with
you
so on this count we find
the defendant the prince family guilty
guilty guilty on disturbing clickbait
hmm guilty of capital uh
clickbait i sented you to
10 years of demonetization oh it's not
sentencing time yet
now we move on to the next topic over
sexualized content
abe would you like to introduce the this
evidence please
yes um for some reason unknown to me a
lot of these family channels
have a mix of content that's supposed to
be aimed towards
children and then the other content is
overly sexualized
so the prince family has videos where
they do like challenges going to walmart
and buying toys they do the gummy bear
challenges
while at the same time they have other
videos where they try on lingerie
so if you please take a look at the
exhibits i have provided you will see
what i'm referring to
absolutely let's see husband rates my
christmas costume
heart eyes now you want me to click
these specific time stamps
yes oh my here what's this there's a
timestamp here i don't know if this turn
around
oh that's totally outrageous you can't
do that can you
i mean he grabbed her ass i don't know i
didn't know you could just do that
especially on a family channel oh this
is what i love
vin diesel i mean oh my turn around
five million views i mean it's a family
channel for christ's sake what is this
it's cool bro you don't like this one i
don't like the shirt the pants is cool
the shirt okay i mean it's subtle i
guess but
i mean right it's decide pick a lane
i mean jesus man uh
next outfit is basically lingerie she
continues to try clothes
[Music]
turn the other way the other way
this way look at them blast marks
[Music]
oh my gosh what's up oh my gosh
oh um so
in this one wife rubs her
father-in-law's back
and chest what so they're playing a
prank
on bianca's husband by
uh by them going in the shower and
rubbing his father's back and pretending
that they're
hooking up in his dad his dad
yes
[Music]
and that's really her twin sister
i mean this shit's so fake by the way
yeah
[Applause]
okay all right
wife walks in husband walks in yeah yeah
smells like fish prank what the l is
that what i think it is
husband feels some type of way and
starts kissing upward
so obviously playing on the vagina
smelling like fish
right are you supposed to touch away
right now
[Music]
hello lady so is this before or after he
smelled fish maybe
this is before
was he usually trying to [ __ ] her on
camera for their vlogs
they have a feud like this in a red boat
i'm gonna start saying that to you i
feel some type of way
girl you and that police outfit
making me feel some type of way
[Music]
[Music]
no don't take my nose don't take my
thumbs up maybe i'm trusting that
something's gonna happen
yeah are you i'm sorry you're at the
first or the second
uh timestamp it says oh he feels some
type of way so let me go ahead and click
kissing her
chest whoo and thanks to zach i
understood this reference
where he says red wings man can you lay
down with his wife away like this
is this the whole video of him trying to
coerce her to have sex with him
what the hell is this video baby lay
down
open your legs baby is this the whole
video
majority of it
god's name is this the dude is literally
coercing her
i get your wings oh he says red wings
so red wings for those who don't know is
when you go down on a girl on her period
and he wants his red wings now fantastic
all the all the kids at home are like
what's a red what are the red wings
daddy
what is this video how did he not smell
the fish yet what is happening
yeah so wait once the fish smell come in
it's it's referring to
wait it's happening right now just
yeah i just had to know your name
i love you so much
i love you so much are you done no
what are you
how did you not smell fish yet oh my god
i love that puff of
she got what she got a fish in her
undies are you ready
it's referencing her being on her period
i believe
what so what's the prank how did she
make it smell
watch a little bit further ready for
what to do it
your face is out all right
i need to clean my face real quick no
let's do it i think i need to clean my
i'll be done
i gotta clean my face where are you
going
i want to go smell myself what oh
you know smaller no that's so stupid
what do you smell her her vagina's
rotting okay so let's do it what are you
doing
i'm going to watch tv no i don't want to
watch tv
bro what is that editing yeah no baby
no i'm cool bro he rubs herself with a
fish in the beginning
oh she rubbed the fish on her vag or
whatever okay
it's disgusting well obviously it's fake
as [ __ ] because clearly
he would smell it immediately and not
you know i mean like he was all over her
it's really dumb and disgusting but i do
find this channel so confusing
with it being like family and
this type of like content like jake paul
yeah they gotta choose a lane here
right okay moving on to who's the
freakiest couple
we have a thumbnail here let's take a
look
who is the freakiest couple what am i
looking at can you possibly get a lower
res thumbnail to present
for the court
i don't know why it came out like that i
apologize who's the freakiest couple
what is happening okay whatever
bunch of people the three couples they
want to know who's the freakiest
oh my goodness here's the first question
exactly the type of content i come to
expect from a family channel
how fast you ever came
understood and then finally
who's most likely to give top in a
traffic jam what does that mean
like to ride yeah what is that oh is
that is that oral
yes yes top top
that turns me on who's likely to give
top in a traffic
i mean again so
thumbnails of other examples husband
rates my explicit halloween costume i
think we already saw that didn't we
oh well here's a thumbnail 5.3 million
views
you like this papi the first one was
christmas ones this year
right right another one raiding my
wife's explicit valentine's day outfit
damn
girl oh my [ __ ] god is tongue out and
everything
four million i see i didn't even know
you could write all my [ __ ] god in
the thumbnail
so here they are defying all conventions
spin the mystery wheel truth or dare
strip
kiss break up twerk touching tongue
14 million wait what is is there like a
is there substance is he is he drenched
in calm that's what it looks like right
do you know what is he drenched in calm
uh a.b
i don't believe so but i do believe
that's what they're trying to pass is
that it's uh
why is he drenched income
now it seems to me that their most
popular content is of the sexual
nature let me let me jump over their
channel and sort by most popular just to
get an idea
of what kind of content people are
coming
to consume i do find it quite disturbing
that they can on one hand
have videos like that and then have ones
featuring their kids doing gummy
challenges
can we see those because i almost don't
feel like they even exist
well here so here's the most popular
videos on the channel the prince family
it's a it's one about their baby being
born
or it's a music video sorry so here's
the calm
cover and calm challenges number two
here she is being
horrifically murdered um
eating challenge so are there kids
in the top um abusing my pregnant wife
prank i'm sorry what
maybe uh abusing my pregnant wife break
oh you gotta wait for the next section
it has has that in there
okay it's juicy so it does seem like
their channel is kind of risque on the
on the whole here
you know it's more about it seems to be
more about them than their than their
kids
here's some i'm sorry if you
if you move it to oldest um range it by
oldest you'll see that it's majority of
their kids
i mean their kids are still in all the
time but i think they just figured out
how to click bait well here you can see
in the banner it's them with all their
three kids
but they have channels for their kids
too yeah so here you go
is there yeah it's all their kids and i
think they just figured out
they could click bait they're the mom
because she's got a fat ass apparently
right interesting you want to see one of
these ela for context
how long ago this is three years so it's
quite a bit
okay so um
so we've come to conclude the over
sexualized content
on their channel um
aien do you have any closing statement
for the defendant
all right people of the courtroom i have
one simple question
we seem to keep coming back to the fact
that this is a family channel
family channel family channel well i've
got a question
how do you make a family
you put the plug in the socket all right
now let's try and reframe the purpose of
this channel what if it's not made for
kids but people with kids
who are always struggling with it
with the duality of marriage
sweet innocent simple during the day
and then just filthy disgusting depraved
nasty [ __ ] at night that's what your
parents do you human parents make me
sick
order order order in the court hey i in
i will remind you
that you are in a human court and you
shall not insult my race as a whole
please keep your analysis to the prince
family
proceed all right i'll turn it back but
i just want to say
what if the prince family is just a
reflection of the human
psyche the duality that parents do have
to face
they're just showing you life that's
what it is
guys all right
thank you for i rest my case and i'll
see you all later i'm out
no no no we have more we have more yeah
hey
ian you're not excused we are not
finished
thank you for your closing statement on
this issue of over this
over sexualized content i do i do want
to say
um his statement um
makes me think and you also asked before
who is the target audience
i feel like after seeing some more
evidence that it probably is the young
parents which will explain a little bit
of what they're doing
right i agree interesting well maybe as
the prosecutor perhaps you can shed some
light on this issue
please present your closing statements
on over sexualized content go ahead
um yeah eli makes a good point i mean
but
any channel that i feel like that has um
references to eating a girl out on her
period and then has
food challenges gummy bear challenges on
the same channel
is a little out there for me so
abey can you for the court's
consideration show
the time like how how close
from when they made a video about eating
a girl out on her period
to a children's content video how close
were those separated
temporally if you would please and while
you search for that
i'll discuss the matter with my my uh
plaintiff is it
no my bailiff
so ela so far reviewing the evidence on
over sexualized
content i have to say that it does seem
overall based on what i've seen at least
recently that the
the target audience is not children
but but the parents yes
and so well there are moments of of over
sexualization for sure
i have an answer for you go ahead please
okay so two weeks ago they have
distracting my husband while he's on the
phone prank where she has her legs
spread in front of his face that's two
weeks ago
and then a week before that they have
love vs hate food challenge with a very
childish thumbnail with a huge
blue donut in it and broccoli is the
is the child featured in the video oh
the an actual child no
no he's not in the he's not in the video
no oh
so i think we've heard enough
uh the court on the issue of
over sexualization while the court
acknowledges that the
content is sexual in nature very much of
it in fact most of their top videos is
featuring some kind of sexual
content the court also recognizes
that children are not the primary
demographic
and so therefore we decide that while
sexual it is not over sexualized to the
point of
targeting children which i think would
be the true crime in this matter which
is something that we've seen many other
youtube
uh channels being guilty of logan paul
uh
jake paul and the likes of these kinds
of of channels which have porn stars
and such super hyper even more
sexualized
and with the primary demographic being
young right or young teenagers for
example here i feel like it's more for
a couple in their 20s maybe right
that still want to feel like
fun young spirit couple but maybe they
already have a kid
yeah and um maybe the dad wants to be
drenched in semen to take a photo and
put in the thumbnail
the court on this matter decides decides
the defendant
is not guilty in the charge of over
sexualized content
now let's move it on to the next one
fake pranks
fake pranks is the next charge a b and
as you know this is a capital offense in
this jurisdiction that says it's for
this is death
ab please proceed uh yes fake pranks the
staple of any bad youtube channel
it has all the usual tropes bad acting
awkward camera placement
there's not much i could say uh i think
it's better to just
enjoy enjoy okay uh ai
ian fake pranks please
hey let's just enjoy as abe said that's
what we did
all right well let's proceed then
abusing my pregnant wife i mean already
this this title alone is really
is really not okay
the one thing i'll say i'm noticing
about the prince family is that they
have no limitation
on the level of click bait or
framing of their videos like they they
will literal i mean they've gone as far
as
as you know no heartbeat yeah no
heartbeat i mean how do you even top
that i don't know
abusing my pregnant wife is is right up
there with it
so let's see video begins with a
dramatic fight with three guys
and then transitions to their intro
again
[Applause]
oh this is the homie they were they were
uh doing their sex games
you hear the slide whistles no oh yeah
that's a great transition i think you're
right
see i i do think that oh yeah
the way they roll the kids the the intro
is kind of problematic a little yeah i
think i think
the prosecution could have entered into
the
evidence the the fact that they
immediately cut to their kids waving to
the camera on their scooters
because because
of course the connotation is that it's
a dis it's like a disney show what
they're presenting here but really it's
couldn't be further from it
you know
but i do that transition was fantastic
can i hear the slide whistle again
there was a slide whistle that's what
ben said it comes in again oh i didn't
huh here's why uh you're like a dramatic
fight and then he slips and it's like
wacky looney tunes sound effects
oh no come on dude how you gonna
and we are back once again guys what
another
how does he endure that how does he keep
a straight face through that
by the way see i feel like if i saw this
last her intro i probably would have
found them guilty of horrible
abusing my pregnant wife frank who are
they pranking
friends
[Applause]
this is horrible i mean this is just
horrible it's traumatic it's insensitive
it's disgusting and of course it's all
fake but
no i know but it has 8.5 million views
and like and like an
overwhelming like ratio like how can you
co-sign abusing my pregnant wife prank
[Applause]
but also the fact that they're so
willing to accept that he actually did
that
means that he really does that no you
know what i mean
no i know it's fake right but like if
this really happened you'd be like whoa
you hit her you know what i mean
but who are you talking about his family
they're all
in on it yeah i know i'm just saying in
a real world setting
yeah somebody like my mom thought i
actually hit you or someone who knows us
yeah
like what the [ __ ] is going on here
right but that's not the case
yeah yeah that's horrible i mean i agree
that that's
that that's horrible and obviously quite
fake as well
um what's your problem it's a prank
excellent defense but they don't need
ain they've got their own defense
[Applause]
what's your problem
oh is this when the fight breaks out
it's a prank bro
[Music]
it's a prank it's a prank bro
it's a prank bro oh yeah
[Applause]
[Applause]
[Music]
he couldn't even swing the pillow
[Applause]
yeah we got a slide whistle the fact
that they put a slide whistle in
is really puts it over the top
well if the question is if is it fake
then it clearly is faith
i love that his ass hit the floor all
right
clearly fake and clearly outrageous and
awful the best scare prank on husband
the premise is that bianca is going to
pretend to be murdered to prank her
husband
fantastic bianna calls her husband to
let her know she's in trouble
let's see how the first act plays out
here there's more blood on the floor and
then i can't walk in here right now i'm
gonna do it in a second
i basically destroyed our room so you
guys can see this was the the thumbnail
you saw where she was
covered and basically like
act scared act like i'm having a panic
attack or something's happened
to basically try and scare him so let's
see oh 12 million i mean the viewership
is insane on this 12 million views
this is absolutely horrendous acting
this is honestly hard to watch it's so
bad
damon finds bianca dead in the tub act
two
the question is is he actually being
pranked or does he know it's fake which
let's decide now
love your [ __ ] is it kind of my [ __ ] bro
oh my god why is the blood look like
orange
yeah it's a very orange so if she was
murdered why would she be in a bathtub
weird murder
let's go what that was a fake ass fall
wait why would he get in the bathtub
oh my god he's clearly trying not to
move the
whatever it is why is he drinking out of
the sink oh he's that guy picking
supposedly
he's fake puking i literally thought he
was drinking out of the sink
he walks in and then immediately just
yaks in the sink real fast
after he says oh my god man this
this is bad acting bro so bad
don't touch it 12 million views
overwhelming life
i mean the fan base is is one of the
i guess they made it from facebook
finally i wish i had their fan base
people that flourished on facebook but i
guess they made it to the yacht
yeah some people make that crossover all
right well this is fake i mean there's
no question about it
his homie yakking in the sink real fast
was uh
perhaps one of the best i gotta watch
that again
i gotta see his homie yak in the sink
real fast again
there's no puking sound he pukes in like
five seconds
it looks like they just put sriracha all
over their thumb
instead of going to help he immediately
pukes
that was the worst acting ever i mean
dude you're not even trying to sell it
all right
um finally damon walks into the bathroom
and throws up okay
right that's that's what we just watched
um husband wait
so so yeah i mean this one is is
wrong on so many levels right but
clearly fake bad acting another one
husband wakes up in swimming pool prank
apparently he can't swim uh and the
premise is that they somehow get his
body
into the swimming pool where he wakes up
and panics oh no not one of these
that's that's such a throwback to josh
baylor
yeah josh taylor lynn did a prank once
where he pretended to be thrown
out of an airplane yeah while sleeping
skydiving while sleeping which
which is one of my favorite fake pranks
of all time and people actually believed
it
yeah those people are out there you know
but you gotta love how he's apparently
sleeping and the
floaties going like like it's so
noisy and he's being dragged
look at this he's so big
okay be careful his head his head don't
even whisper eh
just talking normal volume
okay look at him you guys oh
he's moving this is beyond tom
oh my god three million views uh
overwhelming like ratio
you can jump ahead to when he wakes up
so they're dragging him apparently he
doesn't wake up that's impossible
point of dragging into the water let's
see here
this is quite literally the dumbest
thing
just around you guys he is soaking
what did they what did they date rape
him i mean how do you get someone to
sleep that deep
seriously also it's just a home pool
like hello you're not in the middle of
the ocean
look he's going over there you guys
alrighty
clearly the worst thing ever waking up
damon
that's his father that's waking him up
three that's his dad that's his father
wait his dad looks hella youthful yeah
[Music]
he calls his dad bro that's interesting
beautiful out there
they look like bugs wait what did they
censor oh he cursed
me he looks beautiful out there
what are you all doing mama i mean
you're over the shallow end it's like
one foot of water
he does he does this gag where he drowns
stop it bro
all right let's let's skip to the part
where he apparently drowns in a three
foot deep pool
let's see your phone man
that was totally intentional damian
damien get off
come on
so here's my issue right
my issue is like okay so we've
established that this is for adults
right but what kind of air brained [ __ ]
would actually believe any of this crap
i'm i'm absolutely
uh confounded by this channel you can
touch
he can touch now open your eyes bro
okay all right
those are the fake pranks have a pic
um a b would you like to or maybe
ian should start and then you can
counter uh ian go ahead
in defense of fake pranks please
i mean i mean in situations like this
there really is only one defense it's
like thou shalt not kill thou
shalt not steal it's just a prank bro
like what else what else is there it's
it's a it's a truth known in the
universe
ai in your defense just to clarify is
it's just a prank bro
that is correct yes thank you thank you
for submitting that to the court a b
it's just a prank bro please your
counter um
my counter is also it is just a prank
bro
that is my only counter interesting
prank it's a prank
bro i think that sums up that it falls
in line with all the other channels
that's like the signature line of all
these fake
pranks frank pranksters it's just a
prank bro
is what we've received from both
prosecution and defense i'm a little bit
confused
okay well is is first of all we have to
ask the question
is faking pranks a crime
you opened this saying it was a capital
crime well we're well yeah i'm trying to
i'm trying to flesh out the idea
first we have to establish is faking
pranks a crime
the thing is that
is there any okay how about this is
there any point where faking a prank is
justified
are you violating your viewers trust
when you fake a prank
or is it just a prank bro as both
both defense and prosecution pointed out
i'm thinking back when uh joey salads
faked the
political pranks i think those are
actual crimes
those are actual crimes yeah
um now if we scale it back a little to
this kind of pranks i think it's
more of a gray area it's a matter of
personal taste
in my world view of content that i would
like to consume
this does not exist but
there are other people out there that do
like this
content do you think they know it's fake
the people who consume this
that's a good question they may not care
they may not care
the issue that i'm confronted with here
is abusing my pregnant wife
prank i mean there's certain topics
that again yeah i mean they they hard
cut into their kids playing with toys
while
pretending to abuse his their pregnant
mother
um the best scare prank on my husband
she's pretending to be murdered
the problem with these types of pranks
is that
because i think they they convey that
they're real this is the same thing that
the problem i've always had with fake
pranks is that because they're trying to
convince people that this is
actually happening that it's okay to do
these pranks
because i don't think so because the
acting is so bad
that i almost feel like they're not even
really portraying it as real
that's a that's a big argument to make
and not
so bad i'm not sure the court can can
make that
leap of f uh to accept such a premise i
mean the murder scene with the sriracha
sauce everywhere
they're trying to sell it really bad
acting i don't know
you want here you want to read the
comments to get an idea yeah
because i feel like if if anything
they're just selling it as
entertainment entertainment why would
you want to watch a fake prank if you do
it was fake that that seems to undermine
the entertainment value of it
and again it has 12 million for yourself
in the mind of someone else
so let's watch this kind of content here
let's say sort by top
you know he cares when he goes in the
white air forces
because he hopped in there i don't know
antsy's video but they're all talking
about antsy i wish they wouldn't
if i did this prank i'd legit fall
asleep in the tub
see this these people are are i think
they're presuming that that
that it's a real prank
nobody's insinuating that it's fake and
who
else cried when he went in the bathtub
with her
ela that's one of the top comments
see they cried because it was so
emotional for them
what else are you got there everyone
here i'm trying to
find some uh revealing comments if you
guys are wondering why damien dad said
he
almost he should not touch her is
because if he touches her
and the case is real he would have
gotten arrested because they saw his
fingerprints they
they think it's real they genuinely
and then this person said not funny real
talk again
these people believe it's real and again
with this comment he went in with his
white shoes that means he loves her
so that they think it's real so my
problem with these fake pranks
is that they convey this message to
their audience that doing this kind of
prank is an okay thing to do and that
the reaction that they're seeing
is actually the reaction they can expect
the truth is they're all in on it and if
you try to do something like this in
real life it's a horrible thing to do to
your loved ones and you're not gonna get
the reaction you expect
it's it's a terrible thing to do it's
not gonna be funny to watch no
and that's why they fake it yeah so i
actually the court is going to just make
a
a decision on the fake pranks uh
look there's some things
that it's like hey you thought it was a
girl's ass but it's a guy's ass
but then there's other pranks like i
beat up my pregnant wife or my wife's
dead in a bathtub
the court decides on this
on this matter the prince family is
guilty guilty guilty on the charge
of faking pranks guilty as
charged you are sentenced to 25
000 years of demonetization
and finally is this our final topic here
exploiting children wow now this is a
heavy heavy thing
uh a b would you like to introduce this
final
section yes um so the use of
underage children um for clickbait
and you know just to overall exploit
them is not uncommon on youtube but for
some reason these a lot of these family
vlog channels just have no remorse
when it comes to exploiting their
children and
this family is no exception to that
that's all
but we've seen a clear very strong case
when pretending their child was dead i
mean
it really sets the tone aie exploiting
children
i mean i i don't really give a [ __ ]
about humans so
at least i'm trying to determine if that
is a valid argument or not
i mean you are talking to a robot ai ian
you
i will remind you that you are living in
a human world and you shall not
denigrate an entire species please
proceed with your opening statements
again and i will hold you in contempt of
court if you do not obey
please i mean
you know if there's entertainment value
the views speak for themselves baby
thank you yeah thank you ain fair enough
much better all right
um let's see re-upload of clown pranks
was this one removed maybe
i don't i couldn't find if it was
removed but they did take it down i mean
it's i don't know if it's by them or by
youtube
it's probably by them because of
backlash so this one is now deleted
where they scare the [ __ ] out of their
kids
gives me um well should we watch it if
it's deleted because youtube doesn't
[ __ ] around with this you want to just
describe what happens in this
describe yeah i mean it's not like
violent or anything here let me watch it
here's what i'm gonna do i'm gonna watch
it dan and you don't show it
yeah so she's in a clown mask
these are gonna get super scary she's in
a creepy clown mask oh they're in a full
clown outfit
oh that's so [ __ ] up oh but it's like
the scary clown like
see i would i would rather die than do
this to theodore i mean
this is just [ __ ] up so they're waking
up the kid with the
scary mask wow this is so i feel so
sad so they're in they went in a creepy
clown outfit and mask
and they went and woke up their poor son
who looks to be about what three four or
five
you're going to now they're going
through this hold on hold on one at a
time
what dan i'm sorry i was just asking if
i could just show this still frame to
get
no don't show anything okay you can't
show children in distress
do not show anything um the previous
pranks were all
fake as we are certain of yeah do you
think this one no i don't
i don't because it's so easy to do and
uh kids reactions seem very
real i feel like it's real and it's and
they the fact that they erased it is
kind of evidence of that
yeah um it's horrific i feel horrible
for this kid
and the problem is he he starts crying
and he's obviously in distress and they
don't back down
stop leave him alone this is so
sad but they're there with the cameras
so i don't know
[Music]
right but he but the thing is it's still
creepy he's still a young kid you
shouldn't do that especially when he
starts
crying and he's upset like to happen
like how old
as the parent to see your child into
stress and to con keep digging in
is it's insane is actually super
disturbing
super disturbing can we even show that
part with the crying kid and stuff i
wonder
well we're not we didn't show it yeah
even the audio
well we'll get it rated it's fine
that was really upsetting
really upsetting i wonder how many views
that original one got or if
if they even got [ __ ] because it seems
like their fan base is willing to accept
anything from them
uh the second example is j uh
dj their son almost drowned here's the
thumbnail
let's see oh my god
six million views it's literally their
son this is
[ __ ] insane okay so let's see
apparently the mom
is in a pool with him and legitimately
lets go of him for a second i guess for
click bait
[Music]
[Laughter]
so is that the part you're referring to
that's it yeah okay
so i remember as a kid i was really
terrified of water and being in a pool
so
to actually violate your child's trust
and let him
go even for a millisecond to the point
where his face is submerged
is uh an absolute betrayal of their
trust and
one that would probably severely
traumatize him i mean i'm speaking for
myself because i was terrified
different views on it some people do
that no
like to teach them well that wasn't a
teaching moment though
was it because the if there's a teaching
moment you kind of the framing would be
totally different
yeah i mean certainly i agree if you're
if you're in the pool and the premise is
i'm teaching my child to swim
yeah it's like okay i'm gonna let go of
you that's different
yeah this was more of a thumbnail moment
and they did use it in the thumbnail by
the way
right and they titled it dj almost
drowned which honestly [ __ ] these
people
yeah this is the most upsetting part for
me
the next one uh kiri who is this ab
who's kiwi
uh the daughter kyrie i just thought
i'm sorry son their other son kyrie
kyrie the title of this video is kyrie
got attacked by animals at the zoo
and in the thumbnails goats eating his
[ __ ] hand and his hand bloody
gross what the [ __ ]
what the [ __ ] now if you're not seeing
it it's because um
it's because i don't want to show kids
being abused by their parents even
though it's still up on youtube and not
oh so nothing happened he's just feeding
this nothing happens he's happily
feeding me oh my god oh my god
so he's happily feeding a goat they're
loving it but in the thumbnail what
the goat ate his hand and he's bleeding
i mean these people are shameless man
how are you gonna do that
how are you gonna clickbait your own
children being
being injured it's absolutely shameless
dj takes mommy's car to go to toys r us
12 million views
oh this is from his time so his son has
his own channel dj's clubhouse that's
[ __ ] crazy and has 11 million views
dj takes mommy's car to go to toys r us
what is outrageous about this
one well this one's a little bit
different what is it this one doesn't
have anything
explicit but like the kid is driving
stealing money from his mom's purse
stealing her car keys
and supposedly driving the toys r us by
himself let's watch
so here is a time stamp from this one
okay so this
is content for children i think we can
all yeah agree on that so he's
he's stealing keys now he's stealing
money out of the purse
a supreme bag man i had you
so now we're i mean really you have to
think on this because
if a kid's watching this it really
normalizing
taking the keys and driving and stealing
money from your parents which is crazy
it says 12 million views are and also
they're clearly directing him
so it's the parents idea
of course he doesn't know what he's
doing yeah now here he is
operating the car apparently
starting the car his feet don't even
come close but
the [ __ ] i mean
i mean the truth of the matter is that a
kid
could really watch this and go try to
take the car
right i mean i could totally see that
yeah so when you're operating the thing
about youtube that's so crazy is like
when you're producing content for kids
on television and traditional outlets
there are very strict laws protecting
children
and governing what kind of content and
stuff you can show kids
on youtube all that [ __ ] goes out the
door i don't think on television you
could show something like this because
it's very dangerous to
give that message off and there's a
liability issue as well where on youtube
all that stuff is just is just gone and
so
these people don't take any
responsibility and they don't think
about
really what their content is doing to
people uh this is
yeah i this is to me the worst part of
the whole thing
i hate it but obviously uh
the clown one is and the drowning one
were really hard to watch yeah um ian
do you have any defense for exploiting
children by the prince family
[Music]
i mean you know i i get it i i i've
played pranks on my son too
it's all in good fun you have a son
sorry yeah my son yeah i have a son his
name's dyson
oh you're talking about the vacuum he's
a good see
just the other day i threw a bunch of
pennies everywhere as a prank and
he just swallowed them all up and
totally wrecked his motor
you're saying that you killed your own
son for a prank
i mean he was at a convention for a
while he was being a big baby about it
he should have just sucked it up
you know it sounds like he did try but
who ultimately was his demise
anyways you know it's just entertainment
at the end of the day it teaches them
to you know to to
to to to all right
thank you thank you thank you thank you
all righty he's short-circuited it seems
like he was computing too fast
abe what do you have to say in rebuttal
and closing exploiting children please
proceed
uh clearly the defendant the defense
attorney can't assimilate
what it's like to be human maybe that
goes for all the prince family
fans watchers viewers so i can
understand why he would defend them
but for us normal human beings we find
it very disturbing to
exploit children in this way i rest my
case
well ela on the count of exploiting
children
as i touched on before when you're on
youtube you're able to circumvent
laws and regulations to protect children
therefore
[Music]
yeah therefore you you can find channels
like prince family
that's cultivating an extremely toxic
and dangerous environment
for their family for their kids and for
people watching their videos
this is a problem the problem of course
is that
when the parents are using their own
children as props
in their videos as a vehicle for making
money
who's looking out for the best interests
of those kids at that point
you know what i mean and so
real really who is the parent in the
situation i mean kids must be
protected they must be guided and when
the parent
has a con conflict of interest to do
that
you have a huge problem on your hands
[Music]
i will also submit that the clown prank
is one of the saddest
most disturbing things i've seen on
youtube up there with daddy of five
i feel horrible for that kid no child
should should
mistrust and fear their own parent i
agree with that
as i touched on the drowning one which
they briefly dropped him in the pool
albeit for a moment they used that frame
for the script the thumbnail which was
very disturbing his face was
submerged in the water and they also
said he drowned
perhaps the most grave charge the court
finds the prince family guilty guilty
guilty on exploiting children
guilty ultimately the court
finds the family not on the count of
awful intros not guilty
disturbing clickbait guilty
over sexualized content not guilty fake
pranks
guilty exploiting children guilty
the court finds the prince family guilty
on
three charges of capital fel
youtube felonies and judges them
to a billion years of demonetization
and 10 gazillion down votes on all their
videos
guilty guilty guilty thank you
ladies and gentlemen of the jury thank
you to our
council a b a b put this whole thing
together
thank you so much ab hey i in thank you
for your eloquent
uh albeit um sometimes cold defense but
effective nonetheless and uh thank you
to everybody involved
um this court is now adjourned
thank you everybody for watching and we
hold the prince family
uh we will be taking them into custody
take them into custody
all right you gotta bang the gavel we're
we're not adjourning the court is
adjourned what should i say to
release everyone say you may be
say here you you crazy
everyone may go on with your day thank
you
thank you judge klein
[Music]
you